what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation the three of us are
finally gonna do something that we all
collectively in the middle of a
conversation discovered none of us have
actually watched Star Wars holiday
special during the course with dat John
Humphrey MJ Tesla or Star Wars nerd you
said you tried getting through this
before you got like what 15 minutes 20
minutes out 20 minutes collectively okay
I've tried I hear it's rough but I'm
going in with an open mind hoping that
it's at least enjoyable for whatever I
really don't know what's gonna I really
don't know anything about it wait wait
when did this come out the year before
Empire oh so before Empire it was a 1978
oh so before all that wow you know what
to do use the force to leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated if you
want to do a full-length Reaction watch
along with us that's for our super sexy
rejects on our patreon we got a sponsor
for today's video can't do the holiday
special without getting response we're
gonna justify it
in the spirit of George Lucas himself
but guys
thank you again for sponsoring this
video guys I'm in a onesie I've never
owned a onesie and my epidermis has
never felt more comfortable I obviously
love their clothing I went to the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 premiere
and I even wore the Rocket Raccoon
lounge pants and people would not stop
talking about it easily the most
comfortable one there at the event now
I'm venturing further into the galaxy
far far away you might say with this
limited edition print of grogu AKA baby
Yoda cause the child himself grogu has
traveled across the Galaxy and into our
hearts and now you can meditate with him
in galactically soft undies socks
bralettes loungewear and more available
in sizes extra small to 4XL like I said
the new Star Wars Prince is limited so
grab this bounty now before it's all
gone they also gave me their shorts
which again is so soft and perfect
fitting too even my wife loves to wear
them speaking of my wife I even got this
bralette for her too I said take it off
I'm showing it in the video woman she
loves seeing me in this underwear my
Jedi Mind Tricks to keep her attracted
to me don't work but this underwear is
doing the job wearing it right now I've
never been more relaxed on camera
sitting has just generally never felt so
soothing but yes rejection the hype is
real you're not impressed with me on
these your first pair is on the house
Seth is a promise so to get 25 off your
first order and free standard shipping
go to mionys.com rejects once again that
is.com Rejects and May the force be with
you always I hope they partner up with
us again because
yes
[Music]
Millennium Falcon
yes
[Music]
that's 70s TV frame rate
I know it's an important day
when you're with your wife and you gotta
go to a family event
I'm going to light speed
you'll be celebrating life day before
you know it
that's right is where life day comes
from okay
long time ago
[Music]
Star Wars
[Laughter]
oh he looks so bad was this before his
accident I think it was before the
accident but his hair is like a
different color for a different role
that he had his wife
oh
his father itchy oh
kind of looks like my grandpa Kong
yes Starships
and Star Wars story
there he is yes
she comes from
literally episode three they literally
pulled from these designs it's a
beautiful tree house
oh
God
[Music]
it looks like a sitcom
honey I'm home
[Music]
uh don't worry there's no subtitles
so I hope you're really well read and
wookie
[Music]
break up on it he's annoyed it's visual
storytelling Michael come here
get your ass over here right now young
man
[Music]
taking out the space Train full piece of
[__]
ingly enough their counter thing kind of
looks like a Mandalorian Forge
whoa lovely matte painting oh it's real
shot on location
oh this is no kid what are you doing wow
this is high stakes oh God I'm gonna
throw up I'm running away to the circus
I don't know I kind of like some of
these shots yeah I thought this was
supposed to be
diabolically terrible
famous first words we're only 10 minutes
in Greg I know I'm worried I'm gonna
like it
be that guy
I mean it's not without its charms time
caps exactly it is a time capsule
cassette tapes on kashyyk yeah
so he must be like old old ah because
Chewy's a couple hundred years old
[Music]
foreign
yes yeah it is the surrogus that's right
what the hell yes
what are we looking at
there were drugs in that tape
do you want to try it that stick
[Music]
[Applause]
man in the 70s this reminds me of like
pod people or something
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
I want to know this person's life story
there's not books written about these
guys that there might be honestly my
Star Wars story would be about a
struggling holographic circus performer
[Music]
laughs
I love his expressions
[Music]
and it's really giving it his all
I don't know I'm kind of entranced by
what's happening right now I I'm with
you actually
turn the frogs gay I feel like this is
supposed to be programming me to like
assassinate something
yeah in a crucial moment when you hear
the right toe and you'll start to see
all this happening in front of your eyes
and then you'll wake up having murdered
a whole room so this was this was
actually how we ended the Cold War we've
sent copies of this over to the Soviets
so this is MK Ultra
[Music]
I don't want to do my space chores
this is for sure before Empire yeah
Empire is 80. wow I cannot imagine
finally getting more Star Wars people
were not and then this is what they get
that is so funny
oh
look Hey where's Chewbacca
one at a time I don't know what the [__]
you're saying
[Music]
you're supposed to be watching that you
are too was watching that
it's literally notified you
'll hold it
[Music]
what's up
all I can tell you is that he and
here on
[Music]
schedule blink Markham
let us know you're okay I know him and
he hasn't missed a life day yet right
it's just taking him a little bit longer
to get there that's all you'll make it
come on tomorrow let's see a little
smile
our camel's doing a pretty good job he's
trying
this is a very shrill holiday special
it was a very intense sound
premise of it's actually quite nice now
that I'm thinking about it watch you
come around
I just thought I'd show you some of the
stupid stuff those whoopings purchased
on me those idiot Wookies of his Dark
Helmet
ICS
away
oh he's helping
Greg you're so smart and solo
I use one of these all the time
really
I thought Kathleen Kennedy ruined Star
Wars
she clearly learned from this
I would suggest then that old popular
space Mrs Doubtfire space Julia Child
hack it
but only you know the size of the fight
in your family
what the [__] is happening
this is like a real Slice of Life right
here no that's exactly it I'm not
usually plot obsessed but I'm like this
could have more of a plot
this is an hour and 40 minutes yep and
we've barely cut away from this oh my
God only 10 minutes have passes I
thought this was all right
get ready strap in oh no we're not even
there yet Greg
it can be
is it now this feels so demented
yes
what happens if you only have two hands
have a final
report
I got a fourth one
very nice
is this supposed to be
that's funny with the ladle right on his
nose his nose their nose this is
building out the culture
of it is the post Republic early Empire
inner supplies with real footage from
the film
I swear though all the movie footage
looks like somebody shot a projection of
it like it's like movie theater cam
footage I'm gonna have to run back and
operate the Afghan manually stay on
things here I don't always think they're
taking you home for life
because you've done it every year you
should know how to do it the best part
of this is the reused footage from the
movie
no
it's gonna be a more unnecessary
television programming
this is kind of like one of those Rick
and Morty episodes where they just watch
what's on TV
interdimensional TV or whatever that's
exactly what it is
whoa a different shot yeah right oh
there's a little more handheld it's
gritty now Spielberg did this part
[Music]
you know
what's this for the Ghostbusters
[Music]
han han it's a cultural thing hand is
short for hand
[Music]
head
I'm gonna make everyone kiss you yeah
that's exactly what's gonna happen wow
he's very inappropriate
this guy has a kink that's why he lives
oh look at this stuffed Panther oh it's
really cute I want one is it cute that's
disturbing looks like it's made out of
brush and it looks like a Tim Burton
yeah it looks like it's made out of
sticks and like a real pair of horns
they found
[Music]
oh
Royal typewriter 1971 Edition are we
gonna watch him build oh thank God
I thought you might like this
[Music]
wait a drug
happy life day
oh no he's watching an appropriate
videos is it virtual we'll see
adult content it's a wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry I don't mind when this does like
this [__]
I'm fascinated by this stuff that is
strange Kaleidoscope God the 70s a trip
no pun intended
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
no wonder everybody loves Empire so much
yeah the bar was set so low
wow this is like a really low-grade
James Bond theme or something
exactly yeah it's like an ambient Bond
theme
oh yes yes
this like a
yeah
[Music]
oh
we are excited aren't we
what the hell you gotta be kidding me
I never got this far
wow oh I can't believe this is here
[Music]
oh my God
this is really happening you see I am
your fantasy
I love that this existence
I am your pleasure yeah
oh
wow you know before this began I was
thinking I would put my head into one of
these but now I'm sure I would put my
head into one of these I would just see
you John that's my problem
straight up this is straight up sexually
provocative it's it's more than that
it's erotic he's essential but like a
weird hypnotic futuristic Peep Show
saying yes
[Music]
it's like a bond song John
why can't it always be right now
this is beautiful
[Music]
what what whoa whoa whoa is that the
movie over there is it a glitch it's a
choice
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's really putting her all into the
performance of those no it's it's a
commitment she's great see now I'm like
I kind of love this man I started off
very sexual
[Music]
is going on too long this is where
you're reminded it's a variety show yeah
[Music]
whoa this minute now
this minute now sweet
wow this really is psychedelic
who wrote this
please tell me it was George
he had it the initials were l-s and D
[Laughter]
what is Carrie Fisher not look like Gary
Fisher she's doing their taxes
[Laughter]
you mean they haven't arrived yet
every phone call is the same huh yeah
just calling all their friends to find
out where hon and Chewie are
I got this [__]
and a horny Grandpa
you come to the screen please no he's
coming to the screen already
look I know I can count on you to take
care of my friends and tell their leader
insurance
I can feel it yes indeed ma'am
Now give me a kiss
and do you kiss the screen that call
Advanced and nothing
Leia's here yeah and three vo are here
we're laying on the North side will be
safer there
[Music]
Nice Shot
they made it Daddy's home did I tell you
it must be Chewbacca now damn it
[Laughter]
I like how you can see the edge of the
lens yeah right oh
invite them in for dinner brought to you
by Cheerios the truth of the matter is
she had a terrible fight with her
husband he just stormed right out your
identification all right I said your
identification
today is very important just in times
like this I just found my identification
oh I wish he came back he's good what
the picture you're looking at right now
it's take quite a few years ago that's
one of me I've gained quite a bit of
weight since then
where's your daddy
who is it Daddy what does he do
[Music]
homemade what oh you're coming to catch
him to help me gosh
glad you speak Kearney thank you
I guess very trigger happy okay there we
go
[Music]
let's go into another variety bit
where do you get on with it okay okay
yes Jefferson Starship
[Music]
all right this might be fire
that's Jefferson Starship
[Music]
it's a mic saber yeah
buried in the mix
[Laughter]
melting is Heart of Stone this is like
Bill and Ted yeah I'm gonna change them
through music
[Music]
I love how there's nothing star warsy
about this
is
just a regular music video performance
yeah
thank you
[Music]
wow yeah damn can you get a high quality
version of the song oh there must be
yeah you'll probably get like a whole
vinyl picture disc
yeah
slap of the best man
[Music]
well Jefferson Starship is Canon yeah
boy that's why they had to Rebrand
yeah yeah
[Music]
it's a nice choker too I really like
this song yeah
[Music]
set a direct challenge to The Beatles
they're gonna go higher than the
diamonds in the sky my heart sinks a
little bit every time we cut back to
this house
[Laughter]
here with this instant feeling of trying
not to get bored
this up
[Music]
dude I like him a lot yeah she came back
release the hypnosis
so after this they were like we got to
make the most serious Star Wars [__]
anyway yes
oh boy that's a Mickey Mouse they knew
Hidden Mickey
[Laughter]
Miguel Raton
damn we still got like 45 more minutes
oh I almost forgot
[Music]
I finished the search of this house we
have other areas to cover today it's
crazy how they got Warren Beatty
[Music]
wow that Stormtrooper is freaking
powerful Jesus when my men get angry I
can't oh
control them this guy wants a role in
the next actual Star Wars movie yeah he
wanted to return keep quiet
good luck
[Laughter]
[Music]
has Chewie's son ever come back
thank God they were exiled after this
Revenge
Chewbacca we're long overdue on a
delicate mission to acquire the mystical
Talisman which has been sought by our
forces and by the Empire oh sweet damn
come in Falcon it's chewy but where's on
that's
how it was
electrician course Dr robot yeah it was
literally like wait a second stand by
his near impact uh-oh
what'd he say if something has happened
to Captain Salo and Chewbacca is alone
he will need me to interpret
is that Anthony Daniel I can't tell is
that it was is this happening right now
I don't know like what hot and chewy are
doing no this is something I think this
is separate yeah heading straight for a
moon in the Panna system
why
[Music]
could it used to be sound effects I
think just a few
going sir to see
the second by visual sighting maybe
wowza
[Applause]
Luke shot first
oh no
it was before he was a Jedi master
oh that's really cool whoa
[Music]
I am Boba fit
we come in search of a ship that crashed
near here maybe I can help you I am Boba
Fett
and and growing more power
ful how far
away
don't you think it might be important to
trust him so quickly sir he's our only
chance and besides he seems like a
friend
Vibe you know trend is merely a term
that is often misused did R2 say that
works to that event
the Millennium Falcon
[Music]
no don't destroy it
damn he knows Luke's name and all R2D2
has detected contamination
Otto says it's some kind of sleeping
artist that only affects humans walk
only get in the way
but if you must come on I like his
personality more than what we got in the
live action show
edgy
wow so they introduced him before Empire
Strikes Back And as the whole play and
they didn't
Factor any of this into Empire Strikes
Back they backtracked on a lot of it
he's only got three fingers
oh God he does only have three fingers
quickly located the serum for the
sleeping virus
his real plan oh no Boba Fett's
narrating
Boba Fett
y looks like
all is proceeding as you wish
no
Star Wars holiday special will continue
in a moment the context is really
confusing me what is it now how are they
watching how is this child watching this
yeah and they made an animated movie
based off a real thing that Han so you
know what it Rebels Luke how there is
there's the the space between space yes
they're in the quantum realm okay I mean
this house seems to have like a hard
line into every security camera in the
Galaxy so Mainframe to The Matrix in
here
[Music]
oh
that's a rare compliment for him to give
out yeah
so it does factor into Empire yeah to an
extent it's got way more personality
here than Empire I want to keep
exploring this it doesn't say much of
anything in Empire except Ah that's
Return of the Jedi wrong one my bad
[Music]
the Blaster is not too far off from what
yeah
[Music]
yeah buddy
what the shit's going
it's like us why'd he turn into Walter
Matthau
Ed
literally Jay Leno it's like a newspaper
caricature we intercepted a message
oh it's gonna sneak out of here on
everybody
mainly uses you everyone else was very
suspicious
[Laughter]
he just opened an eye
what is this face he's choosing to keep
his eyes closed Captain Kazan star log
entry 324-1 signing off
Force feet with you was that Rod
Sterling no no oh wait a second it might
have been but it felt like it timeline
makes sense Rod Sterling's Canon
they're not in here
they're not on this shelf or in this
tchotchke this is actually really
frustrating what they're doing yeah
at least they're continuing the
commentary oh no
[Music]
just when you thought I couldn't get
more demonic wow
[Music]
how The Empire stole life day
dude this kid's gonna lose it rip their
arms off yeah just go full chimp it's
probably like 40 years old and Wookie
years
poor thing
that will keep him busy for a while
mom stucks a 20 into the
Imperial officer's pocket
it was her idea the whole time trying to
get this kid off my ass the whole day
oh that's really sad that's Panther
fodder now
[Music]
oh all right I'm not supposed to feel
things lumpy is is a Sweet Sweet Soul
sorry you got decapitated
can we play this at 1.25 speed
one and a half
we're gonna watch it the way it was
intended to be watched this goes from
intermittently interesting to the most
boring shins
thank you for selecting our brand of
mini transmitter uh-huh it will provide
many years of fun and valuable services
like someone's repurposed synthesizer
try
[Music]
try open because it makes a very handy
storage case for your tools until you
need them again
why are we watching
why is this in here it's what it's like
to live in the universe
[Applause]
why are there so many perverse defensive
personalities oh don't do it
wow
[Applause]
it's good character acting in this part
is that this guy's whole thing circuit
yo this Droid is messed up
the oil change
so bad red goes to red
oh
it's too blue
it's crossed over
I I oh my God this is like blunt force
comedy do you think this is comedy
it's come back around relentlessly into
a point where it makes me laugh
we must remain alert for
[Music]
implication of our neurocranial synapsis
they set this as the instructional video
I I think it's uh it helps you as you go
I think it was just malfunctioning as a
sign of their high quality so he should
speak English now use that man or I
suppose Galactic basic or maybe he'll
speak Spanish or something fun make it a
gimmick there you go time now for life
on Tatooine no good to viewers
everywhere in the hope that our own
lives may be uplifted look at all this
b-roll did one of those push-ins this
transmission is unrehearsed and unedited
and is hereby begun without further
comment
moral value
[Music]
at least we got this [__] back
megabind
hey I love the fuzzy guy
you're right comparing my life to this
is better I want to go clubbing on
Tatooine boy
you are not drinking we are
our drinks so the next time I say
what'll it be and you tell me I I can
put it right
fine I thought about it a dozen times
but I had to be sure excuse me I have a
customer waiting I'll be right back one
cup come back soon I'll be waiting
oh
why does he have a big hole in his head
oh gross that's when I developed my
drinking problem
do you think he uses the hole in his
head for why does he have a mouth
I wanted to bring you something and
that's all I could think of if we're
talking I don't get any flowers I am but
you didn't have to bring me anything oh
give me like big Bill Murray Vibes in
quantumania right now
the plight of every female bartender
yeah right what did I mean I decided
what you meant was exactly the thing I
needed oh wow that's explaining
commentary maybe that's why it happened
because I wasn't asking for love anymore
I wasn't desperate I wasn't begging
whining groveling sniveling I just came
in here for a drink
oh dude
it's a 70s John I mean get it boy
this is acceptable don't do this to me
please look I have customers why don't
you sit down finish your drink have
another drink this one's on me is this
how they came up with Star Wars visions
obviously nothing for there excessively
doing the sound disorder
that is Hollow
because I know back soon I'll be waiting
you this has never happened to you
before you've never stuck around long
enough for someone else to leave I don't
want any sympathy for this guy
well the entire Tatooine system
effective immediately all inhabitants
will return to their homes at once
guys get some me and these clothes
for the love of God oh man pull up the
site while you're watching this video
over
get the [__] out you guys not see the TV
P Arthur shot first
four
do you remember the time the guy's
crying
look
I'm sorry we are Satan I saw that guy on
the boulevard the other day
oh
what is the musical Prime friend yes
it's a crime friend I thought I was here
for something like that one might say
it's a tattooed
it's clever thank you why are you
yawning Greg I have not left the screen
though don't worry they literally
they've taken this bop of a song and
turned it into something more yeah it's
clever repertoire expanding slowly but
surely
wow that is just straight out of the
Nutcracker movie
just a big rat we may not drive
but we
[Music]
oh fuzz Jeff good night
song it's not a bad song good night but
not goodbye I don't mind the idea of
this song having the Cantina shut down
full of the Cantina
I like that they they always have the
same Cadence and they just change the
keys just a wee bit yeah
[Music]
give us a hug then
God I've literally seen that guy at the
bar
[Music]
head out
hey
[Music]
what's up da da da
all right
[Music]
it's better if you're giving Craig this
kind of sounds like a you know like a
like a Jewish kind of song that's
exactly
it's very Jewish you're such a dear
friend
dope next year in Jerusalem
the real life day
oh why not stay here friend
buddy
chills actual chills oh are they playing
in the street
this is a weird place to cut away no no
no was she okay I guess she's taking the
flowers now I've got chills
[Laughter]
oh my God I actually played a plot Point
yes
it wasn't just random [__] it paid off
there's a mail missing from this
household and I want you to be here when
he returns
it's possible he's one of the rebels
we're looking for oh
I like that they've been searching this
whole time but didn't know that
[Laughter]
it's on a need to know basis I hope this
isn't the guy that's very pointy and
shooty
don't give it away now kiddo Give It
Away give it away now oh no
there's literally three Wookies just rip
his bloody arms off yeah at this point
now that you're alone they would have me
murder whatever
oh my God kill the kid that's why he
doesn't show up
[Music]
not my PlayStation
jeez
shoot him in the back
[Music]
[Applause]
do we have enough money for the effects
no we do not
[Music]
instantly better
yes
Sweetheart
give me a kiss first
it's okay everybody he's gone
[Laughter]
everything's fixed
I gotta go heaven have a nice life day
but careful a lot of
a lot of chewy
chip of course is clear will you yeah
don't enjoy this moment with your family
[Music]
while I stay for dinner and that's how
chewy became a cuck
[Music]
hi hi everybody my hands solo
Ah that's really nice actually yeah
oh
teardrop shoots his family put them out
of their misery
I love you
I know
[Music]
do it yes grab her ass
started nibbling on her neck
oh just a hug
he's even like a brojo
[Music]
Bill Murray are you sure on how to make
a guy feel welcome glad you're home
Chewbacca the amount of people who don't
check through those peepholes
calling officer b4711 you are instructed
to turn on your comlink immediately
damn they just broadcast it to everyone
two but before 7-Eleven was here with
three other men he packed a lot of food
from this house and he robbed me blind
very well we'll send out a search party
thank you glad that's over I'd always
known he was that way this happens all
the time this day is for you
[Music]
you get a medal you get it
you get a medal ah damn sorry chewy I
only got three
Horizon Skywalker they randomly gave
Chewie a medal that's so funny a
participation award
okay this is gonna get beautiful I can
feel it please do a Wookie song sing it
[Music]
this may have ruined Star Wars
this could have been it
this has only made the whole thing
better
[Music]
happy life day guys in the name of the
father and the Thunder holy spirit amen
[Music]
what is happening I don't care the elves
are returning
to the undying lands yes
[Music]
Frodo with them
God this episode of handmaid's tale is
crazy
who knew this is what it was all
building towards this whole time
thank you
[Music]
this day better be the coolest [__] in
the world
it is indeed true
[Music]
okay
Chewbacca we were so relieved to hear
you were all right oh Chewie we're
relieved all of you are an important
part of my life pal
I never believed him more I hope that
this day will always be a day of joy in
which we can reconfirm
[Music]
than anything else our love for one
another Star Wars was never political
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
worth it worth the hour 40.
Carrie Fisher I love her so much
[Music]
[Laughter]
contractually I have to stay here longer
you can hit the blunt when the take is
over
oh chills chills
chills I've done it I've achieved chills
working for an hour and 40 minutes but
they're here
[Music]
this is literally Les Mis
I dream to dream of time gone by
everyone gets a medal see e3po1
they've established C3 repair and RTD2
as being having no emotions
we are dead inside they have to look
they have wishes but they have no
emotions
[Music]
oh yeah I remember the Star Wars movies
those are really cool man super cool
movies
[Music]
friendly reminder our movies are great
a dark shadow looms over us all
this is not on Disney plus I don't know
I wonder why
they could be making so many fat
streaming dollars why are we looking at
this footage only a master of evil
though to remind you to watch Star Wars
and to buy its merchandise this holiday
season of course
now pre-order special action figures
that won't arrive until far after the
holiday season's completed that's a true
story yes
uh the face you make when you realize
you didn't get the medal
uh what
oh man credits
I don't think so no it never ends this
has more endings than Return of the King
I started off too optimistic guys
yeah you really fell it's only been an
upward trajectory for me yeah
it's called character arcs
what did you do on Life Dick what the
[__] was life day
continuing to be alive what do you do on
Christmas Greg on Christmas you have
dinner festivities dinner festivities
there were drinks
there's movies
literally and they already go look at it
houses it's called The Tree of Life
[Music]
was a man
called it they promoted homosexuality
and drag queens and they had a little
bit of everything in here interracial
relationships
way ahead of its time we need to see who
wrote this monstrosity let's see it okay
producers take them out back shoot them
no Kathleen Kennedy nah
well that explains it wow so many
writers
don't credit John Williams for all the
music he did there it is yeah
well done everyone who worked on it
Ralph mcquarie
a Star Wars consultant eh
that's literally what I um okay
wow wow what a time to be alive guys was
gonna stand for a sec yeah no dude hey
there was like it's Humphrey any
relationship God maybe was there an s on
the end no but we can add one maybe no I
don't have it yes
hey the Burbank Studios
I was
yeah 1978.
I'll keep
yeah
television no it just slapped the word
television on there
oh man all right listen um I have so
many thoughts I can't wait for you to
spill it
um
if I just walk around the room while
you're talking that movie guy was so
anxious just be like Jesus I gotta get
up from this uh yeah I started off very
optimistic it was like the first 10 15
minutes I was like this is not as bad as
anyone has made it out to be like I'm
like I kind of appreciate how we don't
get subtitles with the wookies like this
is just visual literature to pick up on
the body language and the expression and
then follow it and then they had the
weird gymnast dancing [__] and I was
like Ah that's kind of like hypnotically
cool and then Mark Hamill really showed
up and I thought he did a good job and
it was always like whenever they cut the
Han there's like a nostalgic presence
and then I I cannot pinpoint when it
started happening for me but yeah I did
reach a point where I was like this is
the worst thing I've ever seen from Star
Wars this is it if if it is so it's not
so bad it's good to me it got like not
it just became like tedious it to sit
through and very very I like the Boba
Fett cartoon I you would have these
moments where okay that's kind of
interesting I like the the sex lady yeah
that was fine she was cool
um the the music number was my favorite
part I liked uh not Jefferson Airplane
uh singing and their their music number
and uh
Starship yeah Jefferson Starship singing
that was cool Jefferson TIE fighter and
then it just uh it really did become a
slog and
um I was like this is way too long this
is way too long this could have this
could if there could have been an
entertaining piece made out of this if
they kept it under an hour
um but they did not need to it did not
earn its way that's that's a lot of
commercials this was this was the worst
thing I've seen from Star Wars it easily
hands down I cannot think of anything
worse there's nothing worse Michael I
don't care what you say name one thing
that's worse what's worse rise of
Skywalker vastly is superior to this I
don't care what anyone says in one one
thing worse name one thing worse name
one thing worse Star Wars resistance
really all of Star Wars resistance is
worse than this yeah this this this
brought some of the best pieces of Star
Wars to life Greg like Boba Fett
I guess the mandalorians think about
think about that it's true every bit of
Star Wars that we love can find its
origin story from the holidays what I'll
say is that when it comes to Boba Fett
sorry guys I just got a lot of things
when it comes to Boba Fett
um you know I I've always thought it was
kind of hilarious how people were
obsessed with Boba Fett well I'm like
the guys on screen for like three
minutes in total and from like Empire to
Return of the Jedi and he said it has
such an unsatisfying death in Return of
the Jedi that this obsession with Boba
Fett has always been kind of laughable
to me and to see him here and I'm like
oh actually no this would make him
interesting like this was intriguing and
I wish his personality was a little bit
more reflective of that like I like what
they did with Tamara Morrison in Nando
season two I would say
um but I'm like nah this version of Boba
Fett would have been waiting more
compelling to watch he's not he's not
like dinjarin at all and it would have
been more compelling character to watch
on screen so yeah I would say that this
this did that for me for understanding
yep look out of love kashy uh that one
matte painting they got it kept cutting
back to
um B Arthur seeing the occupation of
tattooing these are powerful evocative
that moment that could have worked in a
different thing I'm like there are seeds
here I see for anthologies of like Star
Wars visions of being an anthology thing
where you have these little isolated uh
things and then something else that uh
oh and like there's the the burlesque
show that we really like uh we'll start
you would have loved that Empire strips
back which is like it's not a serialized
storyline that show and it's not just
because there's Attractive people
dancing it there's there's something
really compelling visually about it it's
really enticing it's really funny
um on each each segment is vividly kind
of its own yeah it just doesn't have
that but in that they're at least all
interesting and they don't outstay their
welcome and it was a big yeah yeah that
was the thing too is whenever something
was like a tad bit interesting I'm like
you're way you're gestating here for way
too long we need to we need to move on
um so
I'll be quiet now
um but yeah I I I I really kind of
resented that experience
it sounds really hard and you have all
people
I'm surprised you like turned around
here because you had tried the first one
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
context is everything
the fact this made me appreciate Star
Wars so much more the fact that stars
like Chic people watch the tattooing
video
A Day in the Life the fact that Star
Wars
survived the late 1970s style of things
and was able to like create I mean like
you think about why was it why was A New
Hope such an incredible film it's
because every piece of content for the
most part was this variety show
monstrosity that hailed the 80s I would
have to say wow New Hope because this is
this is clearly caught in the transition
point between the 70s and the 80s well
it's I think the other bit of
appreciation that I have for the holiday
special is that this had one purpose and
that was to sell merchandise and my God
they did a great job you know what you
have bought what did people buy from
this available what kid would want
something
you would pre-order the Boba Fett where
they they couldn't give you the jetpack
piece that shot out the missile because
it was a safety hazard so Boba Fett was
the biggest cell yeah but it was also
repackaging everything all over again it
was like I I imagine this came out at a
time where it was like okay we finally
got the kids to stop talking about Star
Wars for five minutes and this probably
just like even though they hated it like
like like
All Star Wars fans
we hate something we trick ourselves so
long enough in order to to get to the
next thing in hopes it will be better
and you know what that's the state of
bargaining because they believe it's
bargaining and denial and grief it's a
cycle and that's what it means to be the
Stars fan no I mean listen guys it was
absolutely ridiculous uh but also what
an amazing time capsule into the
weirdest most ridiculous time period and
you think about like how many things
happen during this that if it happened
now people would lose their mind over
like I mean yeah did you see the way a
fan base is already now with stuff that
is far superior to this yeah no I mean
like because if you're talking about
time capsule yeah like you know we we
live in a weird time with Star Wars
where there's so much Star Wars this was
the second Star Wars thing right this is
the follow-up to it you hope can you
guys imagine what it must like who's who
in our audience was alive when this came
out and what and watch this error
experience of oh my God this is the
future of Star Wars you know like
Christmas Day 1978 like a hush
came across every household in America
and families were huddled around their
televisions awaiting this this moment
this incredible piece of Television only
40 minutes later a riot broke now we get
bad television on Star Wars and then
everyone's yelling at Kathleen Kennedy
and we have nothing to do with this like
it just becomes no [__] story now one
might say because Kathleen Kennedy I'm
pretty sure her first step in the Star
Wars was during Empire one might say
Kathleen Kennedy saves him yeah
please John please please take it away
uh I I feel like the main thing that
they were aiming to achieve with this
was translating the feeling of waiting a
really long time for somebody to show up
and killing time while you're doing it
because that's basically what you're
watching is just Chewie's whole family's
waiting on them they're killing time
finally he shows up and what are we
doing we kill time we
we watched some TV we're listening to
some music we build a machine and some
Nazis stopped by to bother us for a
little bit uh yeah I mean
I got some blend of General enjoyment
ironic enjoyment and some painful
enjoyment out of this uh I am endeared
by just the tradition of what this is
and to me something like this I wish
could make a return because I can
foresee I can Envision a version of this
that could have worked if as you pointed
out they maybe moved the [__] along
sometimes because that's the thing I
like a slice of life I like a weird
thing that'll plop you into Chewie's
family and no subtitles and all that I
can I can get down with that but what
struck me during the first chunk of this
I was like we've been here a very long
time and what would make this work is if
we checked into this for like two
minutes at a time
between you know a few bits so it's like
okay this is the wrap around and then we
have a bunch of other special things in
between and I feel like this really
skewed the balance to like mostly wrap
around and then like these little tiny
moments of something either just like I
love my I think my favorite thing is the
pleasure machine
because it's because I never thought I'd
see that confronted it's like I like
seeing the lifestyle built I honestly do
like I like the lifestyle and seeing
what they're up to and sure Grandpa's on
his weird dance porn machine I thought
that was a really cool sequence I like
the song it was unexpected and what it
sounded like uh and yeah I liked the
guests I agree it was the Art Carney I
think he was he's great he was great I
wish she came back he is the guy who
shines out is like you are the exact
right thing where I'm always enjoying
you there's nothing there's no
expectation it's great and then you know
you get the fun of like you know the
original cast shows up and sometimes it
works sometimes it's silly and I don't
know I just not want to be there like I
like the idea of a variety show
especially having the animation I
thought the animation you know has aged
but it's certainly lovely for the time
and place that it's set at and I guess
that was just the present moment of what
Han and Chewie were going through that
was delaying them on their way to life
that I don't think so no because Luke
everyone was wearing different sure
[Music]
nah John I think that that you're
missing the magic of Life day in your
life and Greg you're the Grinch I'm most
likely to be like weirdly lenient on
something like that it is some kind of
real like plot you know yeah I'm not
asking for a suspense or some [__] it's
some kind of real think of how much more
expensive that would have been they were
probably given like they're like all
right four hundred dollars they shot
this on the Golden Girl set or something
like that no I was literally there
that's exactly uh I do have to say
though from the bottom of my heart
this was without a doubt my favorite
reaction that I've done with the real
rejects I haven't laughed that hard in a
long time that was rough man that's the
thing is I don't know if I I get what
you mean because I got so bad it's good
enjoyment out of this experience however
if I just put this on in a room with
either myself alone or a couple other
people I don't think the fun would
translate the same way have you I
couldn't even chime in on the jokes with
you guys a lot of times
have you gents ever seen the Caravan of
courage
no the story about the eve walks on
Endor the live action that sounds like
awful I'm excited we're gonna do it
I don't think that's your decision buddy
leave a comment if you want us to watch
it I feel like Greg is gonna love it
is it Canon it might be I count this as
one of the worst because as the worst
because this is Canon Caravan of Courage
is better than this
so you've already seen it I've seen bits
and pieces enough to know they finally
put it on Disney plus John territory now
no well that's
what does that means
this is our I tried watching it before
it was on Disney plus and I haven't been
able to ever find a good copy so I
usually quit a couple minutes in but uh
it's now on Disney Plus
well two of them good all right that's
great yeah give me like six months uh
how would you guys feel if we did a
reaction to the Ewoks animated series uh
from the 1980s it was fire guys was it
no no it's not I just had to check damn
I want more slices of life in Star Wars
like I don't know I would love something
like that and a romance I could get
behind like I don't know there were
things
are good ideas
by this creepy guy in her bar all by
herself no but there was there was
potential for that to have been a fun I
think there was a way that could have
been I think totally I think they could
straight up just do a remake of this yes
they could be good they could do a
remake and just do a better version I
think like weirdly I think James Gunn
when it came to his Guardians holiday
special did obviously he's aware of this
Guardians very much inspired his version
as he said it many times inspired by
Star Wars and I think he did see this
and go here's what I would have done and
decided like we need an actual plot and
let the holiday magic come to life and
it's got to be like 45 minutes no and
honestly because they did the Lego
version which I'd really enjoyed it was
fun yeah but that one's actually good uh
I mean I wouldn't say good but it was
fun uh I love this idea though so Lucas
if you're listening uh every year every
year every year
Chewy's still alive let's have Rey
Skywalker go
on the mission to deliver the little
little they should do what would Ray
Finn and Paul fudgy is all grown up now
right I think if you you know weirdly
weirdly for everyone who's not on board
for the sequel Trilogy if they did a if
they did a good version of the holiday
special with them
and and everyone would be like well it's
better than the first one the first
holiday special yeah it might just get
people on board I think it's so fun to
be self-aware enough to it like this was
so bad it was shut away like George
Lucas did not let copies of this get out
like it wasn't until Disney took over
that it started to really resurface well
so but you know they could do that you
know remember and Roger Scott Walker
when he's like Ray I got to tell you
something and he never tells her yeah
be about that that's such a great right
it could revolve around that could be
the start of that I promised Chewie that
I'd take him to see his family first
do you mind coming we gotta stop off at
Kanto bite first to get some money to
bring presents
oh and we can bring back what's his name
the the cute little Wookie Padawan who
stayed on kashik uh ganji ganji yeah oh
and and then
um you know Ray could go meet Chewie
could introduce Rey to his family and
then they could all be like oh where's
Han he's dead oh what about Leia oh oh
what about Luke CG uh here's he's a
ghost
maybe he can visit Yoda maybe tarsal
will be there from episode three and
Tarkin
dead powerful though we don't
have my Wookies all right well what did
you all think what was the sound Michael
uh what did you all think please leave
your comments questions thoughts
concerns ideas hopes and aspirations if
you were to cast the holiday special
today leave the number of a good
therapist which which one of Chewie's
family would you assign each one of us
of the three characters who would we be
uh hey don't forget to like And
subscribe uh and for you super sexy
rejects thanks for watching along uh
until next time happy life day a shout
out someone actually
I want to celebrate life David flev
Doran because flev sounds like he would
be just the most Bountiful cup of Life
day cheer if I had to sit all day and
just wait and do nothing and get
harassed I would want flev to be with me
so that maybe I might not want to gouge
my eyes out during that experience and
then we could put on you know the
pleasure helmet together and we can you
know watch our own you know a little
song and dance number tailored to our
specific loves and interests I want to
pour a beverage in your head
yeah of course some blue milk in there
oh no I got the zipper caught on my hair
oh no
damn that zipper goes deep too that's
what Flint wants for us
[Laughter]
we love you and uh no we would trade a
million credits to get you back if Boba
Fett kidnapped you and took you to Darth
Vader luckily that hasn't happened yet
but you know stay vigilant out there
it's a strange world love you buddy love
you Flav I need an orange
laughs
[Music]